we the people bil the world nosotros el
pueblo construimos el muro una
iniciativa privada para recolectar
fondos para el muro fronterizo entre
eeuu y méxico fue la primera promesa de
campaña del presidente de donald trump y
que hoy tiene a uno de sus antiguos
allegados en serios problemas este barón
está acusado por la fiscalía federal de
haber defraudado a cientos de miles de
donantes que colaboraron para recaudar
25 millones de dólares
banon y otras 3 personas fueron
arrestadas bajo la sospecha de fraude y
conspiración para lavar dinero un golpe
para un hombre que hasta 2017 trabajo en
la casa blanca y es el octavo ha llegado
el presidente que es arrestado o
procesado por la justicia pienso que el
arresto de banon es sólo un ejemplo más
en donde vemos la corrupción dentro de
la administración de trump y un ejemplo
más en donde los demócratas pueden
simplemente levantarse y decir joe biden
es un tipo decente de acuerdo con la
denuncia banon y otros señalados
recurrieron a facturas falsas ya
comerciantes fantasma para desviar el
dinero la campaña nació en diciembre de
18 con el objetivo de construir 48
kilómetros en tejas al año siguiente el
grupo había levantado 08 kilómetros de
nuevo méxico cerca a el paso banon paso
así este jueves de estar en un lujoso
yate que pertenece a un millonario chino
exiliado a estar esposado ante la
justicia